Добігти до пожежної частини, вдягнути форму й застрибнути в машину.
На все -
5 хвилин.
Це не проблема для цих хлопців, хоч вони й не професійні пожежники.
Так тренується добровільна пожежна команда - скорочено ДПК -
у селі Зав'язанці на Львівщині. Її почали формувати у 2020 році небайдужі місцеві.
У нас була проблема з доїздом пожежної, сюди було 25 кілометрів, це є велика відстань.
І до години часу, поки вони їхали.
За годину вже нічого не рятується.
У нас зараз виїзд стоїть максимум до 15 хвилин і ми вже на місці.
До команди могли приєднатися всі охочі.
Головний критерій - хто живе ближче до гаража, який переобладнали на пожежну частину.
А також - мотивація.
Адже попри ризик для життя добровольці не отримують грошей за свою роботу.
Ми не хочемо за це грошей. Ми хочемо допомагати.
Є можливість - допомагаємо.
Колись як було: всі збігалися з відрами і гасили.
Але тепер нема кому збігатися. Народу щоразу менше,
особливо молоді дуже мало, тож допомагати нема кому.
Ініціативу жителів села підтримав місцевий підрозділ ДСНС.
А також спільний проєкт "Фонду міжнародної солідарності" й польського МЗС.
Команда Зав'язанців виграла грант від міжнародних спонсорів.
Тренування проходили в Польщі.
В рамках трирічного проєкту вони отримали обладнання -
це бойовий одяг і спорядження на суму близько мільйона гривень.
А також пройшли медичні тренування та тренування пожежника-рятівника
за рахунок коштів Фонду міжнародної солідарності.
Це все обладнання, яке потрібне за надзвичайних ситуацій:
генератор, мотопомпа, бензопила, якщо дерева треба відтягнути, відрізати.
Також у команди є гідравлічні інструменти,
домкрати, ножиці, які ріжуть метал,
і власноруч відремонтована пожежна машина.
Цей пожежний автомобіль 1985 року випуску
від німецьких пожежних рятувальників.
Спочатку вони передали його полякам, а вже потім звідти він приїхав сюди, в Україну, на Львівщину,
у село Зав'язанці, і служить місцевій добровільній пожежній команді.
Спершу в команді було 12 вогнеборців, але четверо пішли до війська.
Нині ДПК обслуговує ще дев'ять довколишніх сіл.
За три роки роботи мали більше трьох десятків викликів.
Житлові будинки, господарські будівлі, ваговоз-фуру теж гасили, загорілася.
Багато на що виїжджаємо, наприклад, коли снігові замети застрягають,
автобуси, так само ваговози. І витягуємо, допомагаємо.
Сьогодні ми проведемо такий маленький тренінг з домедичної допомоги.
Адже зараз, коли йдуть бойові дії, нам найактуальніше треба знати.
Так тренуються наймолодші помічники рятувальників-добровольців.
Вони регулярно поновлюють знання про першу медичну допомогу.
- Може стогнати. Що нам важливіше: стогін пораненого чи врятування життя?
- Врятувати життя.
- Так. Може стогнати.
Дар'я Костецька - в минулому вчителька місцевої школи
- відповідає за заняття з молоддю та медичну частину.
Тут у нас повний комплект.
Є термоковдри, бойові турнікети, тут укомплектовані термоковдри.
Я ще і проходжу навчання місцевого супротиву.
У разі наступу чи щось таке ми вже вміємо автомати розбирати,
поводитися з кулеметом-автоматом, гранатою, які види мін є.
Я не можу бути без роботи, я люблю дітей - ото все мої учні,
яких я вела від першого до четвертого класу.
Така я по натурі - я не можу сидіти на місці, я люблю рух, люблю щось нове, якісь випробування.
Пожежники у Зав'язанцях збираються разом не лише на виклики.
Вогнеборці-волонтери стали справжньою родиною.
Разом відзначають свята, а для дітей організовують літній табір.
Одинадцятикласниця Вікторія тепер сама замислюється над тим, аби стати рятувальницею.
Інколи задумувалася, щоб допомагати людям, рятувати їхні життя.
- Не страшно?
- Ні.
Пожежники-волонтери зізнаються: спершу односельчани не сприймали їхню ініціативу всерйоз.
Після трьох років роботи ставлення змінилося.
Чую про них хороші відгуки, помагають людям,
як десь щось, не дай Бог, якась пожежа.
Влітку був табір пожежний, там брав участь мій онук.
Першу допомогу надавати навчилися,
ігри всілякі були, про пожежну було, про медицину було,
діти працювали цілий тиждень.
Онук був дуже задоволений.
У Європі добровільні пожежні підрозділи - звична практика.
Наприклад, у Німеччині професійних пожежних частин трохи більше сотні,
а волонтерських команд - майже 24 тисячі.
У Польщі історія добровільного пожежного руху налічує більше сотні років.
В Україні нині діють майже півтори тисячі добровільних пожежних команд.
Але в ДСНС кажуть, що їх потрібно значно більше.
Адже в селах час доїзду пожежників на виклик іноді сягає 45 хвилин.
Якщо більше їх, то зменшується час прибуття пожежного підрозділу.
Ми собі ставимо за ціль, це нормована ціль
- 20 хвилин з моменту отримання повідомлення,
щоб команда вже прибула до місця події.
А якщо час менший, то це врятоване життя, майно.
Як заохотити людей приєднуватися до добровольчого руху - питання.
Волонтери не отримують зарплати.
Військовозобов'язаних - можуть мобілізувати.
Але в ДСНС кажуть, що місцева влада має змогу підтримувати добровольців.
Керівники громад зацікавлені в безпеці своєї громади.
Потрібно проводити роботу з дітьми, щоб вони підростали і з часом вступали в цей рух.
Також можливо якісь заохочення передбачити керівникам громад,
є у них різні механізми, щоб зацікавити людину бути добровольцем:
звільнення від земельного податку чи зменшення податків.
Щоб створити добровільну пожежну команду необхідно ухвалити рішення на рівні громади,
обрати членів команди і застрахувати їх.
ДСНС надає вогнеборцям-волонтерам пожежні авто,
допомагає оформити нормативні документи й пройти тренування.
За допомогою міжнародних партнерів нескладно отримати обладнання.
Європа зацікавлена, щоб в Україні добровільний пожежний рух розвивався,
тому що це - майбутнє, це менші витрати і розуміння людей,
що вони допомагають в першу чергу собі, своїм близьким, рідним і за це не отримують ніяких коштів.
У ДСНС планують розробити електронний реєстр пожежників-добровольців
і єдину електронну систему.
У майбутньому волонтери зможуть реєструватися в системі власноруч,
чергувати онлайн і отримувати сповіщення про виклик на телефон.